a brand new month is approaching and
that means it's the perfect time
to let go you can play the 30-day
minimalism game and also download
our free printable 30-day minimalism
game calendar
over at theminimalists.com
jackson is asking why did you choose
netflix over other platforms for the
release of
les is now dude they're a good home
netflix is great to work with
um yeah what was that look
no i mean yeah it's it's you know we
really it's not like we
with this specif specific film we didn't
go shopping around everywhere like
minimalism had done so well um
we didn't didn't we didn't we bring
lesses now to a couple other
streamers streaming services no what we
did was we
we took the trailer and the 20-page
proposal that i put together
and gave it to our agent and
gave netflix basically the first writer
oh okay um i didn't realize that now
it was different with the first film the
first film they turned us down twice
right and and we didn't even get a
meeting with them or anything it was
just a hard no
via the intermediary who we were working
through
and so we did our own theatrical release
we put it on
vimeo for 90 days and then we put it on
itunes and everywhere else
it did so well on itunes that it got
their attention
and they came to the table and said okay
yeah we'll
we'll give you uh some money we
eventually found out there was some
[ __ ] going on there as well
yeah which uh we won't get it we can't
really talk about it i'll tell you what
though i'm so glad though
of all the [ __ ] that just happened to
get it on netflix
um because if it would have just went
straight to netflix
um you know we wouldn't have got as many
lessons out of it that we did
yeah and for those lessons i am i am
truly grateful and there's there's
something there about hey look
uh you can be told no twice that's okay
you don't need
permission from netflix or from a
publisher or from whatever to like put
your work out there
and if you do good work like people are
going to notice it doesn't matter how
many times you get told no like do good
work don't worry about who's telling you
yes or no
yeah yeah and i think for for somebody
who's starting out and that
maybe their end goal is to get on a
netflix
um is that a good goal uh
i don't think it's gonna make them happy
personally like it's the same thing as
being like i want three million
subscribers or whatever
um i think that maybe if you want to
make an impact that's one thing if you
really want to
create a story and share it with people
yeah um that's that's another thing
and so uh for me like my end goal my end
dream was
not to get on netflix but i understand
that appeal and i understand why people
would
want that and it certainly does like
well it doesn't necessarily open up
doors maybe it opens up doors but you
still have to like knock on the doors
you still have to go out and find those
opportunities and having that credit
certainly help to say oh i made a
netflix documentary then it's like
like some people see that as like
validation that okay this person's
probably good at what they do could you
imagine if that was our end goal though
of like one day we're gonna be on
netflix because it's like my family
uh i'll be talking that or you know when
the documentary first came out on
netflix they were like so impressed
and they're like oh wow you finally made
it like you're on netflix and i'm like
this is the beginning like this is this
is i made it a long time ago
right yeah yeah right exactly but you
know netflix being the end goal
could you imagine if that we just like
what we did it we're done
like that's um yeah i don't i don't do
goals but like the
the the the time i realized we made it
was our very first tour stop st
petersburg florida yeah it was uh
november 2011.
and eight people showed up it was great
and i'm like we're huggers i guess we're
huggers by the way i've
never been more successful than that
yeah that that
everything that's happened since then
we've had we've spoken in front of 15
000 people before i've never been more
successful than that day
yeah um because i've never needed any
additional validation
and anytime i catch myself feeling like
because it can become addictive right
we've said no to a bunch of media over
the last three years because i realized
like
oh i'm starting to want this yeah
and if i want this that that's empty
that's interesting if you show up empty
you're going to leave empty that's
that's not going to fill
you up if you show up full though like
we did in saint peter's right we should
we showed up full for that yeah we left
full as a result
and so you know your point about the
crowd of fifteen thousand like we have
talked in front of a crowd of fifteen
thousand people that's easier to me
than that crowd of eight that i agree
with that too because
and the the quality of those
interactions with the eight people
versus
you know the 15 000 years of talk the
quality is
so much there's just so much more
quality there with that group of that
smaller group